hi I'm Nicholas Cage and I'm going to
break down a scene for my new film dream
scenario who's certain they've actually
had a dream about
me okay let's explore this this might
get us somewh interesting does anyone
want to share the content of their dream
yes you well um I'm in this Forest
wandering around eating these strange
mushrooms and I'm in like a full tuxedo
for some Reas
reason and there's other people also
dressed up but they're all scared like
Frozen In Fear And then I realized it's
because of this really tall man running
towards
me the whole character I felt Paul
Matthews was an opportunity for me to
apply some of the emotions that I had
experienced I might have been the first
actor who woke up one morning and saw a
viral video called Nicholas Cage loses
you know
what and I watched it grow and grow
exponentially compounding on itself
turning into photoshopping with memes
and t-shirts and what have you and I
wasn't why I got into making movies but
I realized it was completely out of my
control and when I and I didn't know
where to apply those emotions until I
read this script dream scenario and I
thought yes I understand Paul Matthews
even though it's a completely different
situation he was having that experience
of enjoying a little bit of recognition
and then having it turn on him and go
completely out of his
[Music]
control
are you talking to me yes what I love
about that segment is that I've always
enjoyed surrealism and dreams are
inherently surreal and that segment it
shows you just how trippy and how
surreal things can get you can do that
when your subject is dreams when your
movie is about dreams and that is really
what this movie is about you know I'm
sure science can explain away everything
and why we have dreams and and all that
and why it occurs but I like to have a
little bit of magic to it you know even
though I'm sure
99.9% of science is accurate as to why
we have dreams I'm like anyone else I've
had good dreams I've had bad dreams I've
had recurring nightmares usually
involving disasters on an airplane um
but the good dreams you kind of they
change your whole day you wake up with a
bit of spring in your step you know I've
had great dreams about my family um so
it goes both ways like like anybody else
oh he'll kill
us I've never seen
these
beautiful and that's all I
remember huh interesting so I'm looking
at the mushrooms instead of helping oh I
suppose yeah okay let's he another one
anyone when Paul goes in and he talks
about I'm going to give you five minutes
to talk about the dreams and then we're
going to go to the work and he's like
all right let's get into this and it was
Christopher that gave me that note take
the jacket off there and really look
forward to what the dreams are going to
be because of course the more positive
he is about the dreams the more deflated
he becomes when he realizes he's just a
by standard who's inactive Paul Matthews
is a very good professor he cares about
his work he means it he's really
interested in evolutionary biology and
he does his best with his students but I
also wanted to show how he Paul was
receiving this new found recognition and
in that moment he's enjoying it a little
there's a little bit of spring in his
step but the big thing that's kind of
Weighing on him is that he doesn't do
anything in these folks dreams he's just
a bearing witness he's not active he's
not a hero he's he's just looking and
all this stuff is happening around them
I thought that was actually very amusing
in many ways I you know musically I'm
all about Counterpoint and when you can
do the Counterpoint with one character
in the same scene then that's just so
thrilling for me because you can see the
character in real time as a kind of well
you might say
beta male character that is not really
making much of a mark in a positive or A
negative way with with his family and
with his work and then in the nightmare
sequences you see that shift into a more
uh menacing and forboding morose kind of
Aura and to be able to pingpong with
that was great for any
actor
okay so I'm just observing again but
that's funny interesting one anyone
else I was amazed by you know
Christopher first of all his
intelligence second this is his
sophomore effort and the word
Masterpiece came to mind for me because
I've never seen anything else like this
and the movie coales as it works and
when I say Masterpiece I'm talking about
someone who's working at such a fine
level that nothing needs in my view to
be added taken a away or altered and it
doesn't happen often and I thought this
is a real example of a director
expressing his vision perfectly and I
think it helps that he's an editor that
he's actually in in the editing room
cutting it himself I think that speaks
volumes for why the movie
came together as well as it did I was
very well you might say religious about
Christopher's script I didn't part ways
I didn't change a sentence or a word
sometimes I would add something in terms
of a move like the marching in the
nightmare sequence with my daughter that
was something I came up with but by and
large I really adhered to the labretto
that Christopher wrote a24 is a terrific
house very actor friendly um and I like
everything they've produced I I'm I'm
actually quite in awe of their taste and
uh I was happy to be
invited